For example, attacker can insert
data into the packet stream,
to cause the IDS to miss
detecting the attack.
For example, by including
a packet with bad checksum value,
the end host may reject this packet,
and yet, the IDS may accept it.
As a result,
the end host gets the attack, and
yet, the IDS misses detecting it.
Here's an illustration
of the Insertion Attack.
For example,
the attacker sends these packets.
Although out of order,
both of the IDS and
the end host will assemble them
according to the sequence numbers.
One of the packets, X,
has a bad checksum value.
The IDS will accept it.
Therefore, the IDS sees ATXTACK.
On the other hand, the end host rejects
this packet with a bad checksum value.
In other words, the end host gets
attacked by the traffic, yet,
the IDS misses the attack.